once upon a time the GOP was the party
that talked about the virtues of the
free market and free trade we can dare
to dream that at some future date a map
of the world might show the North
American continent as one in which the
peoples and commerce of its three strong
countries flow freely across their
present borders we must say to Mexico
that we want you as equal trading
partners and that's good for both of us
so let's not listen to those who are
trying to scare the American people
those demagogues who appeal to the worst
instincts members of both parties in
Congress should view these trade
agreements for what they are an historic
opportunity to strengthen our economy at
home and advance democracy and
prosperity throughout our hemisphere
then Along Came Donald Trump
globalization has made the financial
elite who donate to politicians very
very wealthy since the election some
polls have revealed that Republicans are
far less likely than Democrats to
support the concept of free trade 57% of
Republicans even back to vice
president-elect Mike Pence's assertion
that the free market has been sorting
the economy out and America has been
losing so if Republicans turned against
free trade and even the free market or
can it be chalked up to blind
partisanship we headed to Bakersfield a
farming an oil town in California's
Central Valley that went 60% trump this
past election to talk to Republican
activists and Trump voters about trade
jobs and Trump
what would you say are the main issues
that motivated people to come out and
vote for Trump in such high numbers here
I think number one is jobs since rubella
is most people they they like the jobs
our business climate or job
lack of jobs jobs were clearly the
concern for Bakersfield residents and
many felt that Trump's promise to
renegotiate trade deals was just the way
to bring those jobs home renegotiating
NAFTA to get a much better deal for
America and we'll walk away if we don't
get that kind of a deal do you think
that free trade is a good thing yes part
of what NAFTA did was eliminated tariffs
between Mexico and the US do you think
that some of those tariffs should be
added back into the deal if he does it
in the sense of what he said before as a
means to pressure the Mexican government
I think that we absolutely have to have
free trade but we should also make sure
in the process that American jobs don't
get lost with an unfair trade deal I'm
totally open to a tariff if they don't
treat us fairly hey they're whole drag
thing is tariffs Trump's talked about
for instance putting a 35% to 40% tariff
on Chinese goods do you think that's a
good thing absolutely I do I think it'll
encourage you know I tried to do this
thing a while ago where I went to
Walmart and I said you know can I find a
product anymore that's made in America
and I tell you what it took me until
aisle six and that is a true story it
was it was a plate set and it was four
times as expensive as everything else
what we have to do is encourage these
folks to come back home and if that
means spending a little bit more on that
product that was made by your neighbor
or yourself and that's what we should do
so you'd be willing to pay four times
more for a plate set made in America
that's a good question yeah a good one
not four times I think we should
negotiate that and would trump at the
negotiating table maybe two times if you
had to pay 30 or 35 percent more for
your goods at Walmart would that be
worth it for you if it was made in
America yes
yeah I would pay more for something that
was made here because it the person who
made it put money on their food on their
table many of the people we talked to
told us that they would pay more for
american-made products and when
Americans are polled as many as eighty
two percent say they also would
prioritize buying American over getting
cheaper goods but what they actually do
tells a different story one survey found
that only nine percent of consumers only
buy american-made products and when
confronted with a real-world choice
between fifty dollar pants and the same
pants made in the USA for $85 only one
in three Americans choose the more
expensive pair a lot of our stuff it's
coming from China like for God's sake
freaking up our flags are being made in
China a lot of them are what do you
think is a bigger threat to
manufacturing in America is it
competition from foreign countries or
government regulation I think it's
pretty equal I think it's pretty equal
so while Republicans have made a sharp
turn against free trade the attitudes
towards the free market in general are a
bit more mixed is the free market good
for America
absolutely 100% the free markets what
made our country thrive competition but
it's very clear that even some
Republicans who claim to favor the free
market still support the notion of
Donald Trump as deal maker in chief do
you think that it's the job of the
president to negotiate deals with
specific companies we've had a country
for many years where folks are not they
feel like they don't have someone
fighting for them on their side
so if that means having somebody step in
and say hey guys let's not move our jobs
overseas let's find a solution where you
can make money but support the country
that supports you do you think that
bailing out GM was for instance a good
idea no I don't think so I know that
would resonate a lot with what he did
would carrier but I believe if you look
and the way was done with GM and the
fact that all the high-end you know high
of executives you know they didn't lose
any money
it seems obvious that for many American
workers who voted for Trump opposition
to free trade and unfettered markets are
sincerely held beliefs informed by the
economic realities they face daily the
question is how will this story end with
Trump elbowing out the free-market
conservatives in the GOP and the anti
trade Bernie Sanders wing of the
Democratic Party ascending will there be
anyone left in mainstream politics to
point out that markets and trade give
Americans more choice and abundance
while stimulating innovation both in
America and abroad or we destined to
find out the hard way what happens when
goods stop crossing borders
[Music]